For most people, Venice is a must-see destination.
To be here on this unique island amid all this culture and history is truly a wonder.
But with its popularity, St. Mark's Square in midday can come with overwhelming crowds.
It'll take an hour for these folks to get into the church.
With so many people traveling these days, if you're not on the ball, crowds can be a real problem.
To me, there are two kinds of travelers:...
...those who waste valuable time waiting in long lines like this and smarter travelers who don't.
Most lines you see, like this one at the Uffizi gallery in Florence,...
...are not people waiting to get in.
They are waiting to buy tickets to get in.
But there are other ways to get tickets.
For example, these people at the Louvre in Paris could avoid this notorious line...
...if they simply bought the city museum pass, which lets you go directly through the turnstile.
You can also make reservations in places like Rome's Borghese gallery...
...to get directly into crowded sites by phone or on the Web.
Or you can arrange your schedule to avoid crowds altogether.
The ancient Pantheon is mobbed through the day but literally all yours early or late.